طب انا كنت مخفي هويه الكويت للامانه يعني
انا ما طلعت فيها لا يمكن قبل ثلاث سنوات
كنت مخفيه شويه فكان يقول لي اين الكوتشنك
مهنه له
فكان شويه موضوع يزعل
[موسيقى]
فيصل الجهني
2015 2019
[موسيقى]
تكشف انا دي اول مره اسرح بهذا الشيء تمام
انا كنت اعاني من المشاكل في حياتي وكنت
ابحث عن حلول لهذه المشاكل
ما لقيتها للامانه فكانت الوسيله للوصول
لهذه الاجوبه هي عن طريق
سماع مشاكل الغير هل هم يعني وجهه النفس
مشاكل كيف تعامله معها للامانه هذا هو كان
السبب الرئيسي
[موسيقى]
طيب هو مسمى مدرب حياه هو لقب ترميزي فقط
لكن هل هو موجود موجود في حياتكم شخص فينا
احنا طالب المساعده عاده يكون من ثلاثه
شرائح الشريحه الاولى هي دائره العائله
ذلك اذا لم تتوفر المساعده ممكن اطلبها من
دائره الاصدقاء لكن ممكن تكون المشكله
فيها من نوع الخصوصيه فما اقدر افردها على
اخوياي او اخذ النصيحه منهم لازم اطلب من
المساعد من الشريحه الثالثه اللي هي مساعد
الخارجيه انا الحين امام امرين يا اني
اروح عند شخص عشوائي او روح ان شخص مختص
كون ان هذا الشخص قال اني انا لايف معناته
وهو يتعهد انه يملك المهارات التاليه
فبالتالي يقدر يساعدني
[موسيقى]
يعني حاله هذه صارت قبل تقريبا ثلاثه ايام
قبل كم يوم هي كانت مجاني عميل كان يقول
انا هدف حياتي انا بصير مليونير
طبعا انا ما اقدر اقول ان هذا الهدف خاطئ
لكن فعليا داخل يعرف ان هذا هدف مو حقيقي
لان احنا عندنا ضوابط للحدث ضوابط الهدف
انها لازم تكون واقعيه لازم تكون واضحه
وصريحه وتكون منطقيه لما الواحد يقول
اباكم مليونير طيب ما معنى مليونير هل
مليون ولا اثنين ولا عشره ولا 20 ما
الحديث انا قاعد اقول له هل انت بتصير
مليونير ولا تبغى الاكتفاء المالي
طيب لما الحين خلينا نتخيل انك انت صرت
مليونير اعطيناك خمسه مليون وش بتسوي فيها
اليوم
[موسيقى]
ما ادري معناته المشكله الحقيقيه ما هي
بالحصول على المليونين والثلاثه هو يعاني
من المشكله مختلفه تماما اللي هي الاكتفاء
المالي معناه النفيس سوء اداره ماليه
فبالتالي يعني كثره الاسئله والجلسه تبين
عندنا انه المشكله الحقيقيه اللي عم
يلجالها او الهاتف الحقيقي الامريكي
انا ذكرت لك انه الاخصائي النفسي مدرب
الحياه واللايف كوتش يلتقون عند عده نقاط
احيانا او اواجه الصعوبات في حياتي لكن
الصعوبات هذه ما هي سلوكيه هي تحديات
اتخاذ قرار اني اغير مهنتي
لما اخذ التحدي هذا والمشكله واروح عند
اخصائي نفسها بالمثال هل هي مشكله او تحدي
سلوكي لا هذا شيء ينظر الى المستقبل نفسي
فبالتالي انا لازم اطلب المشهوره من
الشريحه الثالثه من ناس خارج الدائره
الاصدقاء او الاقارب او مش ما كان السبب
في التالي انا هنا اختار اللي اروح عند
لايف كود او روح عند شخص مختص مر بالتجربه
هذه
يبدون ان فيه نوع من الحساسيه شويه
طبعا يعني اي انسان يحس انه
دائرته او مهنته تهاجم او يساء لها بطريقه
ما اكيد انه راح يتحسس تجاهها يعني انا
جدا متفاهم هذا الشيء
هذا تحدي كبير انا انصح جميع الناس ولم
يسالون عن مؤهلات الكوتش هل تملك الاعتماد
من الاتحاد الدولي ولا لا تملك الاعتماد
هل تملك شهادات من اكاديميات مختلفه
طبعا هذه ما هي دلاله على الكوتش هذا ناجح
ولا لا ولكن هي مفتاح من الكوتش هذا اجتهد
بالحصول على
نماذج معينه اساليب معينه وبعدين انظر
الناس دائما تنظر مع شيلات عن طريق
الشهادات وانا دائما انظر لها على ساعات
الخبره
[موسيقى]
كم عندك ساعات عمل يعني انا اشتغلت على
نفسي خمس سنوات تقريبا
بلاش مجاني
والسبب اني انا مستفيد الاول انا ابغى
ارفع ساعات الساعات العمليه ابغى استزيد
علم ابغى اكسب خبره
بعدين اقدر اقيس
في احد الايام جاني صديق من المقربين
بالنسبه لي وقال لي فيصل انا محتاج جلسه
بس الجلسه تكون مختلفه
قال لي كلام كان ثقيل على صدري
يعني خلال ساعتين ونص وصلنا الاتفاق معين
انه
ايه ده تبي تقدم على هذا الشيء تقدر تقدم
عليه ولكن خل نستنفذ الخيارات الموجوده ما
راح يضرنا شيء
والحمد لله كان في وفاق بيني وبين النقطه
هذه وكانت في متابعه بيني وبينك بشكل يومي
اليوم هذا الشخص من اكثر الناس نجاحا في
محيطي
[موسيقى]
مثل المشاكل السلوكيه النفسيه احيانا في
ناس تعاني من حالات اكتئاب وقلق حاده انا
ما اقدر اتعامل معها لان كنت محتاج تدخل
مختص
في حالات المشاكل الاضطرابات النفسيه او
الامراض النفسيه هذه لها مختصين النفسيه
طب انا كنت مخفي هويه الكويت للامانه يعني
انا ما طلعت فيها لا يمكن قبل ثلاث سنوات
انت مخفيه شويه
لما بديت اظهرها للعالم
تضررت منها
احد يقول لي شو تسوي في حياتك ليش قاعد
تقرا في هذا الشيء الفلاني او او فكان
يقول لي ايه مهنه له
فكان شويه موضوع يزعل
فهذا يمكن احد الامثل اللي كنت اقول له
طيب تعال
خلينا ناخذ جلسه على السريع كده
الله يعافيكم تحت امركم
[موسيقى]